[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on ressent effectivement
une forte augmentation des prix
notamment ce qui est visible c'est
vraiment à la pompe quand on fait le
plein avant bah 60 euros on avait
effectivement de quoi faire 600 700 km
maintenant c'est 90 euros donc il y a
effectivement une réflexion qui s'impose
avant de avant de faire un déplacement
j'ai toujours fait plus ou moins
attention donc c'est un peu problème de
ma génération tu fais un petit peu
attention et voilà c'est tout c'est vrai
que je vais maintenant des fois même aux
dates limites
je pense que l'état de refaire un petit
effort
c'est déjà apprécié ce qu'il faut le
carburant il devrait voir un peu comment
remédier à ça j'ai vu qu'hier il y avait
une augmentation paradoxale ce RSA les
aides de la famille pourquoi ne pas
basculer également sur le panier de la
ménagère avec ce genre
l'inflation on est bien d'accord Hérode
abîme votre pouvoir d'achat sur qui
peut-on compter le consommateur peut
bien sûr compter sur les mêmes compter
sur l'état on va venir mais il peut
aussi peut-être compter sur les vendeurs
et en général les intermédiaires les
distributeurs la grande distribution qui
très souvent se targue à grand renfort
de comparaison de même de benchmark de
prouver que son chariot est moins cher
que le chariot de la concurrence je ne
dis pas qu'il y a de triche c'est
forcément vrai puisque les produits sont
bien sûr sélectionnés et que d'un
magasin à l'autre d'une enseigne à
l'autre les marges ne sont pas les mêmes
il y a des comportements de marge il y a
des péréquations de marge ça signifie
que il y a des produits dont la marge
est très faible dont on a baissé le prix
de vente le plus possible pour pouvoir
attirer les clients et puis il reste une
fois que le client est sur place et bien
des produits qui eux ont démarche
confortable et permettent bien
finalement de compenser ces cadeaux
entre guillemets que l'on fait aux
clients Émile Zola dans le bonheur des
dames avait déjà dressé des prémices
cette technique marketing Émile Zola
1883 le consommateur face à l'inflation
il peut aussi tenter de se défendre
parce qu'il a un revenu à disposition il
n'est pas pourrait-on dire obligé de
consommer tout son revenu il doit
considérer que sa décision aujourd'hui
va impacter demain si je consomme tout
mon revenu aujourd'hui sans penser au
futur et que demain je perds mon emploi
les conséquences seront dramatiques et
donc l'arbitrage consommation non
consommation consommation présente pour
une consommation future ça signifie un
arbitrage consommation épargne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]